last Saturday in an attempt to
demonstrate outrage at something some
three million people across the country
mostly women participated in women's
marches the scattershot platform for the
march included public funding for
contraception and abortion equal pay
protections for illegal immigrants
anti-israel activism and taxpayer
subsidized tampons among other various
and random causes what United them
hatred for the reality the Donald Trump
was sworn in as president of the United
States on Friday two contrasting images
emerge from the March itself first
people filling the streets out of pure
unadulterated but vaguely motivated
frustration second some of the most
egregiously perverse speeches and
signage in modern political history
while the left celebrated the first
image isn't this a sign of a political
uprising in the making it ignored the
second image which is far more likely to
backfire than to generate enthusiasm
that second image was promulgated by
celebrities like Ashley Judd who was
once considered a frontrunner for the
Democratic nomination for the Senate in
Kentucky there has been actress raged I
am a nasty woman I didn't know devils
could be resurrected but I feel in these
streets a mess stash traded for a toupee
I am nasty like the blood stains on my
bedsheets we don't actually choose if
and when to have our periods believe me
if we could some of us would you do not
like throwing away our favorite pairs of
Underpants tell me why our pads and
tampons still tax when viagra and
Rogaine are not okay meanwhile thousands
of women Don's hats or pink knit
caps with cat ears designed to rebuke
Trump for the access hollywood tape in
which he said he could grab women by the
blank and get away with it they marched
with signs reading leave my pee alone
and if abortion is murder then certain
sexual acts are cannibalism and this
pussycat without the cab bites and she
slays NER all pro-choice America hands
it out signs with similar messages this
reduction of women to their constituent
body parts is kind of ironic coming from
the same side of the political aisle
that says that men sometimes have
vaginas and that some women have penises
but more importantly reducing female
priorities to killing babies and
increased funding for maxi pads
it actually objectifies women instead of
recognizing that women have all sorts of
political views instead of recognizing
that many women believe they ought to be
left alone by government in order to
pursue their dreams the women's March is
declared government has to treat vaginal
possession with a sort of victim status
deserving special protection the
suggestion that the government must
guarantee special privileges for women
because their biology makes them somehow
lesser or that abortion rights are
necessary to achieve equality it reduces
the fight for female equality to the
fight for female sameness which is
insulting to women and it's off-putting
to voters if these women are so
concerned about vulgarity why are they
embracing it if they're so upset Trump
supposedly reduces women to body parts
why promote that same silly thinking the
left tried to run the war on women in
2016 they lost now they're doubling down
but apparently so long as they can pat
themselves on the back for their
unearned moral superiority
they'll be happy I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show so we are here and
Donald Trump's been a very busy man
which means that we have a lot to go
through President Trump has signed a
slew of executive orders he's been
extraordinarily active on Twitter which
means of course that gives us lots to
talk about we will get to all of that in
one moment first we have to say thank
you to our advertisers over at helix
sleep so as I've said before on the
program I am an extraordinarily light
sleeper I don't tend to sleep well some
small noises
wake me up if the bed isn't comfortable
then it's hard for me to sleep which is
why I am so excited about being
partnered with helix-loop-helix sleep
it's a mattress company and what they do
is you go on their website over at helix
sleep comm slash ban helix
sleep comm slash man and they give you a
questionnaire what kind of beds you
liked it liked it hard you like it soft
do you like it firm do you like a
breathable do you like to sleep in kind
of cool or do you like it to be warm and
absorb heat well helix sleep calm they
then send you and then send you the
mattress in the mail and by the way you
can get a mattress that has two
different settings if you're if you're
married or have a partner and and you
want the bed to have two different
settings because one of you likes it
soft from one of you likes it more firm
helix can do that as well they send it
to you in the mail in a box and then you
unpack it and it inflates automatically
and it is super comfortable it's so
comfortable that we took a more
expensive mattress we had and we
actually moved it out of our room and
put the helix Sleep mattress in it is
definitely up to the quality of our
sleep they run that 3d biomechanical
model of your body through their
algorithms that they've created to help
create the most comfortable mattress
you've ever slept on if you don't like
it by the way you can return it it
arrives in about a week shipping is 100
for you have a hundred nights to try it
out and then if you don't like it
they'll pick it up for free and they'll
take it away no questions asked so it
really is no risk it's a lot cheaper
than a lot of more expensive mattresses
as well it's it's a great company we're
very excited to be associated with them
helix sleep comm / Ben and you get 50
bucks off your first order which is a
pretty good deal
helix sleep comm / Ben make sure you use
the slash Ben so they know that we sent
you as a way of saying thank you to them
for sponsoring the program okay so lots
going on so Donald Trump has been very
very active in the last 24 hours
and he's done a lot of good things and
he's done a couple of things that are
not so good so first off the big
headline of the day is that the stock
market has broke in 20,000 the Dow Jones
Industrial Average has now broken 20,000
and this of course is great news I mean
it's somebody with money in the stock
market that's fantastic and it is
amazing how the entire left thought the
world would implode when Trump was
elected so if you go back to their
predictions New York Times faux
economist Paul Krugman he wrote this is
my specialty if the question is when
markets will recover a first pass answer
is never never they never recover from a
Donald Trump election when Donald Trump
took office by the way the the stock
market the DJIA
was at the Dow Jones was at like 18,000
200 it is currently over 20,000 so
Krugman is wrong Kurt - well the Vanity
Fair you remember him he's the crazy
kook who is on with Tucker Carlson
holding a binder and just being
generally weird he tweeted in September
that in preparation for Trump presidency
he sold all of his stocks in his kids
education accounts and he urged everyone
else to do the same which would have
been a terrible move but it's not just
kind of the kooky left professor Eric
zitzewitz of Dartmouth College he said
the global markets would tank by 10% if
Trump was elected the former chief
economist for the International Monetary
Fund said we should expect a big
markdown in expected future earnings for
a wide range of stocks and a likely
crash in the broader market there's a
hedge fund called Bridgewater associates
they said that from potal I was elected
the stock market would would dump 2,000
points in a day
Citigroup forecast the S&P 500 would
drop between 3 and 5 percent instead by
the end of the day of the election the
DJIA had risen had had risen 1.4 percent
the S&P 500 had risen by 1.1 percent now
all of that is great news and it
demonstrates the panic on the left is
overstated by the same token just to be
intellectually honest which we like
doing around here you know the
Republicans are saying this is the Trump
effect this is because of Trump right
Kellyanne Conway tweeted out the Trump
effect Fox Business said president
Trump's early policy follow-through
propels down to 20,000 there's a problem
with this logic I was here during the
Obama years during the Obama years in
March of 2009 the stock market was at 66
hundred sixty-six hundred when he left
or when he when Trump was elected it was
at eighteen thousand three hundred
thirty two so that's a two hundred and
seventy seven percent increase over the
course of his term today the stock
market is at twenty thousand fifty one
as of the time about forty minutes ago
that's a nine point four percent
increase well i'm i remember we didn't
say that Barack Obama's economic
policies were glorious because the stock
market was doing well so you can't
change the metric for success in the
middle of the game you don't get to say
stock market doesn't matter when it's
doing well under Obama but now it
matters a lot when it's doing well under
Trump there's stuff that Trump's gonna
do that's good
there's stuff that's Trump's gonna do
that's bad I'm very pleased the stock
market is doing well a bit of
intellectual honesty would be nice the
stock market does not generally operate
based on political events like elections
it really doesn't it operates much more
based on underlying market fundamentals
the market already prices in the risks
that are associated with the election of
various people in the political system
when you buy a stock you tend not to
think about the politics of the
situation you tend to think about the
underlying value of the companies do you
think it's overvalued or undervalued
that the global economic situation what
is the stock market like in China you
know that sort of stuff has a much
broader impact than an election and
pretending the Trump is responsible for
all of the rise is just as silly as
pretending that Barack Obama was
responsible for all of the rise so I
just want to get that out of the way
since that's the big news story of the
day and their reasons to celebrate Trump
which we're gonna get to in one second
but I just want to I just want to be
intellectually honest about the stock
market thing because I think that it's
setting up a situation where next time
the stock market goes up under a
Democrat then the Democrats will say the
same thing and then we'll say no and
it's just silly it's just silly okay so
here's the stuff that Trump is doing
that's good and he's doing a bunch of
good things again you sort of have to
separate Trump into what he says on
Twitter and what he's saying publicly
and then what he actually does what
doing is listening to the people around
him so for example he is now acting on
the border wall which is what he has to
do this was by the way the part of his
agenda I thought he was most likely to
follow through on because Donald Trump
likes building things big glorious huge
things with his name on them that are
golden right he he loves that stuff so
the idea he wasn't going to build the
wall of course he was always going to
build a physical barrier along the
border as well he should
he's now signed an executive order that
that is supposed to basically tell the
executive branch to go ahead and start
constructing that wall or continue
constructing that wall he also said that
he was going to increase plans to hire
5,000 more US Customs and Border
Protection agents that's actually low
I'd like to see that up to 20,000 even
the gang of eight bill which sucked had
20,000 additional ice agents Border
Protection agents not 5,000 that needs
to increase dramatically Trump has also
said that he is going to withdraw
funding from sanctuary cities which
certainly should be done there's no
reason the federal government should
sponsor cities for violating federal law
so good for Donald Trump on all of that
also he's expected to limit the number
of refugees admitted to the United
States 250 thousand a year down from a
hundred thousand and imposed a temporary
ban on a lot of refugees immigration
experts expect that in the later in the
week he's going to suspend the issuance
of visas to people from countries where
he can't get adequate screening that's
Syria Sudan Somalia Iraq around Libya
Yemen I'm actually shocked that it
doesn't include more countries it should
probably include Afghanistan for
starters which should include Pakistan
for starters there are a lot of
countries where extremism is
extraordinarily high and we have a tough
time screening and putting a
postponement on while we get a better
screening system seems to me a basic
logical thing to do so good for Trump on
that really that's that's good stuff
Donald Trump followed through on all of
that the part that he's not following
through on apparently is daca and DAPA
getting rid of the executive amnesty so
good for him on the wall good for him on
the border agents good for him on
sanctuary cities really really good
stuff terrific stuff from President
Trump on that good for him on postponing
a lot of this this immigration from
countries that we can't check that's a
really positive development because we
don't need more immigrants who are gonna
come here and participate in terror
or support them so that is a good thing
as well all of this is really good it's
important to mention in the context of
immigration that the border wall is less
significant then the then the daca DAP
executive amnesty that Obama push
because most of the people who are
staying in the country right now are
people who violated their visas the
border wall you know it allows us to
know when people are attempting to cross
the border presumably you set up some
sort of touch fence like Israel has so
that you can determine when people are
trying to cross the border it would stop
people from crossing the border without
us knowing about it but the fact is that
net immigration through the southern
border has actually been pretty flat for
the last couple of years despite these
well-publicized kind of spikes that have
been happening with people crossing the
border and being captured by ice the
real problem with illegal immigration is
not people crossing the border that we
don't know about it's the fact that we
know about all these people and we don't
do anything about all these people that
a lot of people cross the border and
then they have a baby and then they're
tied here or they cross the border they
overstay a visa and we lose track of
them or they cross the border and then
ice grabs them and then I sends them to
an immigration court and then they are
released on their own remand which is
ridiculous and then they just disappear
right that's really the big problem with
immigration that's gonna be much more up
to Attorney General Jeff Sessions and
we'll see how he enforces the law but as
far as this sort of stuff good good for
Donald Trump other good stuff from
Donald Trump so Donald Trump is talking
about his Supreme Court picks he
mentions one guy who I think would be
really good and one guy who I'm a little
more dicey on the guy who he's
mentioning who's really good is a judge
named Neil Gore his name is Neil Gorsuch
he's from the 10th Circuit Court of
Appeals and from what I have seen he is
quite good and again there's always a
little bit of mystery about these folks
because they don't rule on every issue
and they don't speak out on every issue
particularly because Democrats tend to
shut down anybody who speaks clearly and
openly about judicial issues if you say
roe v wade is the worst constitutional
decision in the United States since Dred
Scott and Plessy versus Ferguson and
maybe Skinner versus Oklahoma if you say
that then the Democrats will just kill
your nomination so what you get is a lot
of stealth candidates a lot of people
who you don't know much about them but
here's what we do know about Neal
Gorsuch if he is selected next week and
this is coming from somebody who opposed
Justice Roberts I think I was the only
conservative in America who opposed
Justice Roberts on the grounds that we
didn't know enough about
him so here's what we know about Gorsuch
he was appointed to the Tenth Circuit by
George W Bush in 2006 he has a really
good legal resume obviously went to to
University of Oxford and Harvard Law
School he did clerk for Byron white and
Anthony Kennedy neither of whom is
conservative obviously Byron white and
Anthony Kenny are not conservative so
that is a something of concern some of
his high-profile rulings however have
been pretty textualist so for example
Neil Gorsuch on on what is called the
Chevron rule the Chevron rule this
obscure constitutional law but it
actually matters a lot under the Chevron
rule the judiciary really does not
review the rulings of administrative
agencies so if you have a run-in with
the EPA the EPA has basically its own
court system and if the EPA rules
against you if an Administrative Court
rules against you judges typically don't
overrule that Gorsuch thinks that's
ridiculous he thinks that there's no
reason why the judiciary should be able
to have its power removed and handed to
the executive branch that's a good thing
quarters such has written a pretty
sterling dissent from the 10th circuit
in the case of Hobby Lobby so Hobby
Lobby is as you recall was a case where
the federal government was trying to
cram down on private companies that
these private companies had to purchase
Obamacare for people in spite of their
religious objections they had to cover
contraception contraceptives in spite of
their religious objections Gorsuch wrote
a really good dissent in that particular
case that one comes up he is apparently
a textualist he is very hard on poorly
written criminal law he has talked about
judicial activism and the fact that the
left uses the courts in order to press
forward its case he's written a book
very critical of assisted suicide so
this is somebody who who tends to be
more along the lines of Justice Scalia
as far as the other person who Trump is
apparently considering this is a
Hardiman right so this is Judge Thomas
Hartman who is a US district court judge
in Pennsylvania sits on the same court
as trumps sister apparently he's from
the Third Circuit Court of Appeals and
right now there are people who are
handicapping this as him being the
front-runner some people say Gorsuch is
the front-runner I don't know anything I
don't know that hardiman's record
betrays anything particularly
conservative versus
is not conservative so I don't see any
red flags really there's not a lot on
substance he he's in favor of sort of
tougher crime and tougher on crime stuff
but he's kind of an aside he's kind of a
cipher to me he was confirmed 95 to zero
by the way for the court of appeals
whenever somebody's confirmed 95 to zero
it's a good indicator that they're too
much of a cipher for you to trust right
you should actually have a certain
amount of controversy with your Supreme
Court nominees otherwise how do you know
that you're getting it right if the
Democrats don't think that you're
getting it wrong so I prefer Gorsuch to
Hardiman we'll see who Trump picks on
all of that so that's the story with
Donald Trump's actions and then there's
Donald Trump's Twitter then there is
Donald Trump's Twitter and we'll get to
Donald Trump's Twitter in just a minute
plus you have to stick around over a
daily wire.com you have to become a
subscriber and stick around because
we're gonna talk about the most racist
ridiculous
Democratic Party townhall ever ever and
the Trump's done so much I talks a lot
about that but I want to get to what the
Democrats are doing because that to me
is the key to the whole political news
cycle what the Democrats are doing right
now is doubling down on racism in a
release of your way we're going to talk
about that as soon as we're done here on
Facebook over its daily we're calm go
over there and subscribe eight bucks a
month gets you a subscription to daily
wire.com annual subscribers still get a
signed copy of my book true allegiance
we have a bunch of new goodies that are
coming out for subscribers the Shapiro
store is due to open very very shortly
and you get to be part of tomorrow's
mail bag you get to watch the rest of
the show live be part of tomorrow's mail
bag watch clavin's show live be part of
his mailbag and as I say lots more
goodies coming for subscribers behind
the paywall daily wire com you just want
to listen to the rest of the show go
subscribe at itunes definitely subscribe
at itunes we have now tens of thousands
of subscribers and we are of course the
most listened to conservative podcast in
the United States
[Music]